all right good morning good afternoon
everyone welcome to today's webinar
high-throughput CRISPR cast nine genome
engineering in primary t-cells being
presented today by Judge Hulk West an
assistant professor of medicine at
Northwestern University today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by a lab roots and sponsored by
horizon discovery my name is Louise
Baskin I'm a senior product manager at
horizon and I will be moderating today's
event before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is intended to
be interactive we encourage you to
submit as many questions as you would
like at any time during the presentation
to do so you simply type your question
into the ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and click on
the send button we will hold several
questions for Judd to answer during the
Q&A session at the end but additionally
we do have scientist standing by to
answer questions as they come in during
the presentation we'll answer as many
questions as we can but if there's some
that we don't get to we will send you a
written response by email also you'll be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window if you want to enlarge it just
click on the double arrow symbol at the
top right hand corner of the slide and
if you're having any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab that's down to the top right
of the presentation window or you can
report any problems through that ask a
question box
continuing education credits are being
offered for this webinar so please click
on the continuing education credits tab
which is located the top right of the
presentation window and just follow that
process to obtain your credits and you
can also check out the other tabs that
contain helpful resources that might
answer questions that could arise
following the webinar so now I'd like to
go ahead and introduce our presenter dr.
Judd Holt quest
dr. Holt Quist recently joined
Northwestern University in Chicago as an
associate professor of medicine his lab
specializes in the adaptation of
proteomic and functional genomic
technologies to primary models of
disease to better understand a host
pathogen relationship now his work on
CRISPR technologies with dr. Nevin
Croghan at UCSF led to the development
of the first gene editing platform for
primary t-cells and the identification
of several novel pathways that
contribute to HIV replication and he'll
be sharing some of that data and some
new findings with us today
he's currently funded by the Third Coast
Center for AIDS research and the
American Foundation for AIDS research to
uncover the molecular mechanisms that
underlie HIV latency and reactivation
we're really pleased to have him
speaking today to share his techniques
and findings using high-throughput
CRISPR caste 9 in primary t-cells so
with that I will go ahead and turn it
over to judge for his presentation
fantastic thank you so much Louise it
really is a pleasure to be here and
really to start out my presentation
today I really just wanted to share with
everybody these e/m images in the upper
left of Aquila cell in the upper right
of a jerk at cell and in the bottom
three different images of primary cd4
positive T cells taken 0 24 and 48 hours
after stimulation and the reason I
wanted to share these images is because
all of us as researchers really rely on
immortalized cell lines like heelas and
jerk ATS in order to make discoveries
and push our biology forward but we can
tell even through a microscope at low
magnification that these cells are
actually quite different from each other
even at the surface level and when you
dig underneath to the underlying
molecular architecture the differences
between a Gila cell and a jurkat cell
and a primary T cell are actually quite
stark and while this might not influence
much of normal processes basic
metabolism it does have very profound
impacts when you're trying to take these
findings and then translate them into
curable or functional cures so my
research is really focused on human
immunodeficiency virus or HIV and that's
really where I really got into the field
of primary t-cell editing so human
immunodeficiency virus or HIV is the
causative agent of AIDS and it really
took off in a worldwide epidemic in the
1980s and currently there are 37 million
people infected and that number
continues to arise this virus starts as
an RNA molecule which is then reverse
reverse transcribed into a DNA molecule
that inserts itself into the human
genome this means once you are infected
you're infected to life and subject to
all of the Associated social
psychological physical and financial
burdens that come with that status
there are a number of small molecule
inhibitors to help with the treatment of
HIV but there is no cure as such there's
constant and ongoing research as to how
we can develop new small molecules and
new agents for the treatment of HIV
infection and for possible curative
therapies
now much of the work that has been done
prior to now has really focused on using
immortalized cell lines as model systems
for HIV replication such that we could
attempt to understand on a global level
the genes that are involved in
replication a number of genome-wide RNA
interference or RNAi AI studies that
were conducted at the beginning of the
century identified in each one of them
nearly 300 genes that were thought to
play a role in HIV replication however
when we go back and use meta-analysis to
compare these three genome-wide studies
we find that of the 300 genes that each
one of these studies identified only 3
genes were shared between all 3 studies
why and how there could be such a large
disagreement between three very large
and reputable laboratories as to which
genes control HIV replication were in
fact the subject of many more
publications in the years to come but
all of these publications came to two
primary conclusions the first being that
cell lines do not really authentically
recapitulate the intracellular
environment of a host cell and the
second is that RNA technologies are
severely limited by their transient
activity they're incomplete knockdown
and significant off-target effects
and so this led us to want to try to
identify genes that control HIV
replication using knockout strategies
primarily in primary t-cells
so if you're used back the labs of
Jennifer Doudna at UC Berkeley and Alex
Marcin at UCSF came up with a
revolutionary CRISPR cast nine
technology to allow for the delivery of
CRISPR cast nine ribonucleoproteins
directly into primary cells so CRISPR
cast nine is a two-part system a
programmable nucleus that then binds to
a guide RNA that guide RNA then directs
the programmable nucleus to specific
sites of the genome to create a double
strand break when the endogenous repair
mechanism within the cell repairs that
break it does so without necessary
fidelity repair meaning that you can get
knockouts and if you provide a
homologous template you can even direct
knock in
now what jennifer doudna and Alex
marcin's lab did that really allowed for
this technology to be used in a primary
cell is rather than delivering CRISPR
Cass 9 on a lentivirus or with a DNA
construct they purified the caste 9
protein and the guide RNA in vitro
complex them together and then used
electroporation to deliver them to the
cells the reason that this is so
effective is actually for five main
reasons the first is that this does not
rely on any transcription or translation
of nucleic nucleic acids rather you're
delivering the protein and the RNA
directly into the cells
the second major advantage is that you
enhance the activity of the CRISPR caste
9 you're delivering bichri complexing
this RNA and caste 9 normally in a
bacteria where CRISPR caste 9 was
originally discovered the bacteria is so
small that the RNA and the proteins find
each other relatively easily but in a
mammalian cell when you're trying to
express them from DNA or RNA the protein
needs to be exported from the nucleus
folded and then find the RNA before
being really edit by pre complexing the
RNA and the protein you solve that space
problem the third main main advantage of
using these CRISPR rnps is that the
protein complexes are actually cleared
from the shell shortly after editing so
no residual changes are left to yourself
beyond the actual edits that the
proteins do to the DNA this requires no
selective markers and no selection so
you deliver the CRISPR RMT's do their
work and then they're cleared from the
cell without selection and finally these
of this technology allows for the
editing of primary cell types most
immortalized cell lines have been
selected for their ability to robustly
be grown ex-vivo but most of these cells
lack a lot of the endogenous repair
mechanisms that are found in primary
cell types this prevents the use of DNA
or lentiviral constructs and many
different types of primary cells and the
use of CRISPR cassadine rnps gets around
this
as well so based on this breakthrough
from the downtown marcin labs in 2015 we
teamed up with them to generate a high
throughput platform for primary T cell
editing using CRISPR cast nine RFPs the
way that our platform works is we
isolate T cells from donor blood we use
those primary human T cells and activate
them with seed III and cd28 these
activated T cells can then be
electroporated with CRISPR cast nine
ribonucleoproteins generated ex-vivo
these polyclonal knockout cells that
result from the select operation can be
expanded and continued to use them in
downstream phenotypic assays these pools
can then be verified that the knockout
worked at both the sequencing level and
its immunostaining immunoblotting level
now what this really does is it allows
for us to use primary T cells as a
genetic platform truly for the first
time and what we did with this
technology was first begin to
investigate some of the genes known to
be critical for HIV replication so how
HIV enters a t-cell is the use of two
receptors called cd4 which is the main
receptor and ccr5 which is the co
receptor we decided to target ccr5 on
the t-cell surface to see if we couldn't
generate primary t-cells that were
resistant to HIV infection but before I
go any deeper into the data I wanted to
share some details about the protocol
itself which reflects many months of
technical tweaking to devise a system
that can generate primary knockout
t-cells in a high-throughput and
efficient manner
so just for your information all the
details for reproducing this platform
are available as a protocol currently
uploaded on PI archive the number is two
zero five five zero zero as shown up
above here
so each reaction can tolerate anywhere
between a hundred thousand and 1 million
primary t-cells in a volume of roughly
20 microliters and we can achieve
editing efficiencies over 99% with the
average efficiency being between 70 and
80 percent consistent among between
donors and low-side each reaction takes
less than 2 hours and can be done in 96
format so you can do hundreds of
manipulations in a single afternoon all
reagents are commercially available or
can be readily synthesized in-house so I
really hope that this platform can be
widely adaptable to many different
people's uses furthermore this method
supports multiplexing and can be used to
easily generate double and triple
knockout cells and importantly we see
little to no toxicity after 24 hours so
the cells continue to divide on the
continued be stimulated as normal and
they can be infected as per usual with
no observable adverse effects
so first I wanted to go through a few
considerations for the handling of the T
cells and the ribonucleoprotein
complexes are aren t use themselves so
in our experience the culture conditions
are a critical variable when optimizing
crisper cast 9 delivery for primary T
cells they are most susceptible to
editing when fully stimulated but we've
also found that strong stimulatory
signals can deter the long term
viability its population so to strike
the right balance between editing
efficiency and viability we first
stimulate ourselves with plate bound
anti cd3 and soluble antecedent 28 for
72 hours prior to nucleus section and
then this is followed by a second round
of stimulation with B bout ante CD to
328 and beads
immediately after the nucleus section
these conditions may differ depending on
the experimental design but the editing
really appears to be highly efficient as
long as you can achieve complete
activation so for example we've had
great success editing pH a il-2
stimulated so but this method is so
strong that it often comes at a cost of
cell viability so it's really all about
finding the right balance and what works
for you in your experiment
so another consideration along these
lines is that when you're generating the
rnps I always recommend that you have an
excess of guide RNA I synthesize mine at
a ratio of two parts guide RNA trace RNA
to one part cast 9 and this really
ensures that the Cassadine protein is
fully complex with the guide RNA a
variety of cast 9 proteins and a variety
of guard RNAs with different
modifications are available from
different vendors but they all appear to
work consistently with this methodology
finally one last consideration is that
given that each cell only has two
alleles to edit the RMPs are actually
quite in excess in each reaction and in
fact if an RMP
is highly efficient it can be
multiplexed with other rnps
for the generation of double knockout or
even triple knockout cells this can be
useful in the study of functional
redundancy or at the stasis
when I do my own double or triple
knockout generation I find that it's
most effective to generate each of the
rnps individually and then mix them at
equal molar concentrations prior to
delivery to the primary T cells
when it comes to the actual experimental
controls and the design of the CRISPR
rnase reagents it's very similar to any
experimental system where the right
controls are really critical for
downstream interpretation of your
results so generally each plate of the
screen or each small experiment should
have at least three types of control one
a positive control with a strong effect
on the phenotype being assayed two a
negative control or a non targeting
control and then three a toxicity
control so for a positive control I
recommend at least two distinct positive
controls that target genes with
predictable effects on the phenotype
that's being a say-so in the screen I'll
be talking about a little later we use
actually three different positive R and
P controls that target genes with known
impacts on HIV replication these are
really helpful for being sure that your
assay is working as it's supposed to now
the second type of control is the
negative control and for this we
recommend including at least two
distinct non targeting guides per
experiment and if you're doing this on a
plate they should be distributed
randomly so for example you can correct
for edge effects on your plate the final
controls I recommend in any experiment
is toxicity control do we recommend
actually targeting a gene that's
essential to cell health or cell
division so in the screen I'll talk
about in a little bit we actually use
the gene CD canine which is essential
for cellular health of primary t-cells
so in most donors successful knockout of
this control will result in significant
toxicity and cell death in comparison of
this wealth cell count viability and the
phenotype of those experimental wells is
really useful for setting your
thresholds for analysis and identifying
other potentially essential gene in your
experiment for experimental targets
themselves we recommend ordering three
five distinct guide rnas per gene for
most low side this will yield at least
one guide that exhibits high efficiency
editing and as you'll see this redundant
information can provide additional
confidence in the phenotypes that you're
seeing
but it also provides really important
digital information when you're
considering genetic variations between
your different donor samples
finally I wanted to go over a few
considerations for screen design before
we jump into the data so I always really
strongly recommend that when you're
going to be doing a high-throughput
application that you validate your
system using a positive control in a
pilot experiment so this pilot really
provides critical information in helping
you to optimize your control optimize
your time points determining your
sensitivity windows etc for the ease of
setup all of the guide RNAs can be
ordered from commercial sources pre
arrayed in 9600 place and really
conveniently this orientation can be
preserved for RP generation as well as
Electra prett electroporation nucleus
section new HIV spreading infection or
additional phenotypic assays when
considering which s is to run however
it's really critical to minimize the
downstream handling because at large
scales even doubling an experiment can
very quickly create unanticipated time
and cost burdens and I'd also recommend
that you consult with domain experts
prior to experiment initiation to ensure
that the design is both technically and
statistically robust so when use
carefully this approach can be
incredibly powerful as I hope some of
this data will demonstrate
so here I'm showing a pool of t-cells
isolated from a donor that was then
either left unmodified treated with
Cassadine protein alone or treated with
CRISPR cast nine rnps
targeting the ccr5 locus and as you can
see in the upper panel is slow we are
staining for cd4 on the x-axis and ccr5
on the y and while the unmodified and
cast nine only treated cells have levels
high levels of ccr5 in the cell surface
when we target ccr5 we can see that
expression is completely dissipated when
we stain for cd25 or cd4 we see no
change in those cell surface markers
meaning that this editing is specific to
the ccr5 locus so we can take these cell
pools and then infect them with a ccr5
tropic HIV in the green bars I'm showing
results from two different donors top
and bottom in the green I'm showing the
percent of ccr5 knockout at the protein
level the blue bars indicate the
replication of a ccr5 tropic virus and
as you can see in the calf nine only
treated cells we get nearly 100%
infection and with the ccr5 knockout
cells we see an over order of magnitude
protection from infection and if we take
these viruses and pseudo type them with
a different viral envelope that's not
dependent on ccr5 we can fully restore
the infection this indicates that one
these cells are not overtly sick or
overtly toxic they can't support viral
replication but two we can edit them
successfully to prevent HIV infection so
this really opens the door for us to use
the system to better understand not only
HIV but autoimmunity and other t-cell
mediated processes
so what we wanted to do next was really
begin to move away from one gene
targeted studies to see if we could
actually do this hundreds of genes at a
time remember I had mentioned at the
beginning that there were several
genome-wide RNAi eye studies that
attempted to systematically identify
host gene that were involved in HIV
replication while those studies didn't
work out we're hoping that this platform
will now allow us to test hundreds of
genes at once directly in primary T
cells with knockouts that's enabling us
to come up with a more complete list of
host factors that are truly required in
vivo
so the jeans that we decided to target
sort of as a pilot for this our 435
jeans that were previously identified as
HIV human protein protein interactions
so a series of affinity purification
mass spec experiments had identified 435
human proteins that were known to bind
to HIV proteins the reason that these
435 are truly interesting is because
they should be enriched for functionally
important factors the second main reason
why studying these would be a good first
pass is that because there's a protein
protein interaction it gives us a
mechanistic handle for functional
follow-up and finally we wanted to test
these 435 to see how truly scalable and
effective this technology could be
across many low SCI and across many
donors
so the strategy we use is laid out here
we arrayed crispr RNA designing three
crispr RNA per gene across all 430 of
our targeted genes in 96-well plates and
complex them with Castine protein in
vitro these CAF nine rnps were then
electroporated into activated t cells so
we had isolated from two to five
independent donors to create polyclonal
knockout pools in 96-well plates these
we were able to expand and replica plate
and then infect with HIV with a GFP
reporter this infection was then
monitored at three five and seven days
post infection by high throughput flow
cytometry in parallel we extract a
genomic DNA from these primary T cells
and did deep sequencing over our CRISPR
cast nine target sites to quantify the
percent editing that we were able to
achieve in each one of these populations
therefore we could cross validate our
HIV infected e data with our mutational
efficiency data to generate a map of HIV
post factors
wanted to run through some of what we
learned with the deep sequencing data
before going through our infectivity
data so for the deep sequencing we
decided to use a targeted strategy to
look specifically at the sites that we
were targeting for crisper cast 9
editing using bioinformatics algorithms
we design primers flanking the target
site in each one of our specific guide
RNAs we used robotic fluid handling than
to insert index primers and generate our
amplicons for deep sequencing
now remember CRISPR cast 9 does not have
a directed repair mechanism but rather
relies on endogenous repair machinery
that means within each one you're going
to get a diverse series of repairs and
we can use these different repair
outcomes to quantify exactly the %
editing that we got in our original
nucleus section reaction of all of our
1296 CRISPR cast 9 cut sides we were
able to get good sequencing from 1,000
79 or roughly 83% and we were able to
get 71% of this information in more than
one donor
what we found was that overall our
editing efficiency and primary t-cells
using this technology was quite robust
across all low sigh in the genome so
remember we had used three guides per
gene and here I'm highlighting the most
effective guide in pink the second most
effective guide in green and the third
most effective guide in blue for each
one of the low-side what we can see is
that for the most effective guide across
every low side we had an average allelic
editing efficiency of roughly 75 percent
and this covers again sequencing data
over 1,000 79 guides across four hundred
and thirty different editing sites so
overall we were quite pleased with how
effective this technology was regardless
of where in the genome you're targeting
second thing that we were quite pleased
to see was that the editing efficiency
itself was quite robust we were able to
achieve knock out over 50% of alleles at
340 of the 430 targeted low side when we
compared this donor to donor we found
very very high correlation using this
technology in one donor versus another
so here we're showing all of the editing
results from one donor versus another
and as you can see we're getting an
r-squared of nearly 75 0.75 which is
quite extraordinary considering that
these cells from completely different
people and then have been edited in
completely different reactions and yet
we see the strong concordance in editing
efficiencies meaning that once the
efficiency of a guide that you use one
is likely to predict the efficiency when
you use it a second time
now these guide RNAs were not always
perfectly correlated one donor to the
next and what we found is that when a
guide wasn't correlated donor to donor
it was often due to single nucleotide
variations between different donors
so here I'm just to illustrate this I'm
showing you an example of some of the
sequencing results that we got on the
very top we have listed our reference
sequence and have boxed in our guide RNA
now I have the results from two donors
than listed on the right hand side now
donor number one actually had very few
sequences that match the reference
sequence and in fact was homozygous for
a snip at the location indicated by the
red arrow and that's can be annotated as
SN V minus eight
now this snip was homozygous and donor
one and we saw very few editing events
as listed below that
however in donor two we saw that this
was a heterozygote for the snip and for
the reference sequence and when we look
at the reference sequence we see a
depleted number of wild-type reference
and a large number of editing indicating
that that one mismatch protected donor
one from editing at this site whereas
the wild-type sequence in donor two
allowed for robust editing in an allele
specific manner so the donor to donor
lack of correlation in some of these
cases is due to snips at specific ID RNA
sequences
but overall we found very high
correlations at most of the sites on
average between point six and point
eight
now one of the coolest things that we
were able to do with this data is now
that we had sequencing data for over a
thousand different sites across many
different donors if we were able to use
machine learning algorithms to actually
predict what kind of repair outcomes you
get from editing so we took all of our
sequencing information and combine this
with information about the flanking
sequence the distance to the cut site
chromatid information gene expression
and micro homology and use gradient
boosting machine learning algorithms to
create a prediction software that will
predict the kind of crisper cast 9
repair you will get from a cut and we
call this algorithm CRISPR repair
outcome or sprout
what we found is that all of the CRISPR
guide RNA the repair could be predicted
based on primarily two things the
sequence of the guide itself and the
chromatin organization at the site of
cutting
so here I'm showing the sequence
features that actually were found to
promote an insertion or a deletion but
one of the most striking features that
we found from our machine learning
algorithms were that the target site
itself could predict whether or not you
would get an insertion or a deletion
upon doing the repair so for example if
you have a G immediately next to the cup
site you are very strongly likely to get
a deletion as opposed to an insertion on
the contrary if you had an a immediately
adjacent to your payoff sequence you
were very likely to get an insertion
rather than a deletion all of these
tools can be used to design better
CRISPR cache 9 tools in the future
the second incredible thing that we
found besides that the sequence can
predict the repair outcome whether that
the chromatid architecture of the cell
also dictates this repair outcome
so at almost every site we found very
large insertions we're talking somewhere
in the range of 10 to 20 all the way up
to 80 to 90 base pair insertion and we
found these at almost every cut site
that we were looking at when we aligned
to these long insertions back to the
human genome we found that it matched
specific chromosomal location and so if
you look at the upper right panel here
we're doing a heat map of an insertion
relative to where it originally came
from in the genome and when you look at
the hi-c cromoz in context map which is
mapped immediately below that you can
see a striking resemblance between
insertion probability and the chromatin
architecture itself indicating that when
you're creating these double strand
breaks what happens in a rare number of
occasions if you're actually stealing
part of an adjacent chromosome and
inserting it at that CRISPR site which
was absolutely astounding to us when we
first saw this data rod it was
absolutely beautiful we had never
predicted to learn so much just from
doing these sequencing reactions at
these sites but this is again only half
of our data set this is really only
focusing on the sequencing but we also
have paired Insecta vut II data for
every one of these wells that we looked
at
so remember that we infected each pool
of cells with the GFP reporter HIV virus
and monitored the infectivity at three
five and seven days post infection what
we found is when we did this in
technical triplicate here we're plotting
the log twofold change in infection from
the median I in all three of our
replicates we found very high
reproducibility in our infections
and we found very high reproducibility
in our controls
in every single place that we ran as a
quality-control
we ran the same six reactions on every
single electroporation reaction to see
how reproducible not only our
electroporation was how reproducible our
editing was but how reproducible our
inspection was and so the first three
columns here at day three represent our
non targeting controls so these are our
negative controls and we get very strong
correlation of the infection right at
the median of the plate when we knock
out cxcr4 though which is a necessary
HIV co-receptor we get over negative
four log to full changes in HIV
infection all again directly in these
primary t-cells when we knock out ledge
s which is a chromatin receptor we see a
one to two log fold change and when we
knock out cdk nine which is necessary
for viral transcription we see a similar
change and this change and these fold
changes were highly reproducible again
across all of our donors across all of
our reactions indicating we have a
robust pipeline
so here's looking at the data from all
1511 guides that we transfected in
across all of our donors plotting the
infectivity on the y-axis and what we
can see is that a number of different
genes that we targeted for knockout
resulted in very strong defects in viral
replication while others that we knocked
out actually increased viral replication
somewhat
so we took this data and we plotted it
relative to our editing efficiency in
order to generate for the first time our
pair data set of hiv-infected e relative
to CRISPR editing so on the x-axis we're
showing the guides as arranged by their
impact on affection so this is the
editing efficiency on the x-axis and on
the y-axis we're showing the log fold
change of infection and what we can see
is that when you have very little
editing you don't see very much change
in HIV infection but as you get more and
more editing percentage you see these
changes to the genome that result in
really stark differences to how HIV can
replicate so how do we determine which
one of these are meaningful events and
which ones are not
we had to draw a cut off somewhere so
what we did is we did titration
experiments putting cxcr4 knockouts so
these are cells that cannot be infected
with HIV and titrating them with our non
targeting controls I'm using statistical
analysis we were able to determine that
we need at least 30% editing in our
population in order to identify HIV host
factors applying this cutoff on
we can determine a false discovery rate
of roughly 1% and therefore we can
identify 86 different genes in our data
set that we can both edit and that
showed a striking impact on HIV
infection 269 of the genes that we
targeted we were able to edit
sufficiently but we saw no change in
infection and eighty genes we were
either unable to edit or ended up
killing the cells and so we were not
able to get a reliable infection read
out
now what you can do with this data is
remember we had a physical map of how
the HIV human interaction looks we can
take our functional data and apply that
back onto our physical map in order to
derive a functional map of HIV host
factor complexes combining both
proteomic and genetic data in order to
lay out the interactions as they play
out both physically and functionally
this is a little bit hard to read at the
scale so here is the same data now
presented in heatmap format where we're
showing all the genes here indicated in
blue when we knock it out decrease HIV
infection that means their HIV
dependency factors or that they're
required for HIV infection anything in
red actually is an HIV restriction
factor so it acts as an antiviral factor
and when you knock it out increases HIV
infection now this is incredibly crucial
data set because any one of these genes
if we can target with a small molecule
could be used as a future therapeutic
none of this was correlated with cell
count
so we filtered out any genes that could
be toxic and in fact when we looked at
the cell count of only those factors
that decrease HIV replication we found
that the cells group better because they
were being protected from HIV infection
and when we knocked out a restriction
factor of these antiviral factors the
cells grew works because the virus was
acting in a cytotoxic manner
now nicely we are able to recapitulate a
not a lot of known biology in this data
set so for example here I'm just showing
the physical interactions that are known
to take place with the HIV tap protein
the tap is required for HIV
transcription and it hijacks the pfb
complex in order to replicate
now what I'm showing here on the far
left is a schematic of how it's known to
work in human cells is that the PTFE
complex composed of CD canine and see
CMT one highlighted in blue is hijacked
by this tap protein and taken to the HIV
transcription complex now CD canine and
CC and t1 also bind to the three
proteins shown in red hex and one mep
see and large seven and these actually
act to soak it up and prevent HIV from
hijacking this complex so nicely what we
found in our data set is when you knock
out any of the proteins shown here in
blue so CD canine and CCN t1 we see a
decrease in viral replication and when
we knock out the three competing factors
hexa one mep see or large seven we see
an increase in infection completely
consistent with what's been known in the
field
get an additional layer to this data set
remember that we took multiple time
points at days three five and seven and
what we found is that if you actually
look at the day three data alone it can
be used as a proxy for genes that act
early or late in viral replication just
as an example of this here I'm showing
some data from the HIV this protein
which adds late in the infection cycle
to counteract antiviral inhibition by
the app of x3 family of anti viral
protein and what we found was that if
you look at day three of our heat map we
see very little in fact if 'ti changes
from knocking out any of the factors
associated with this however at days
five and seven we are able to see strong
insect ivities indicating that this data
set not only can stray eight phenotypes
based on their functional or physical
characteristics but it can also do so
temporally
so of the 86 host factors that we
identified in this study almost half of
them have not been reported yet
so while roughly 40 of them have been
seen before in the literature over 40 of
them have yet to be reported which just
speaks again to the critical importance
of using primary cells to really
understand what's happening at the
molecular level just case in point you
know one of these pet factors that we've
been looking at these new factors that
hadn't been reported before is
non-histone chromosome protein - like
one or a 10 HP - l1 whose knockout
inhibits HIV replication here you can
see in the blue bar the replication over
time a virus in a population of cells
with n h p1 knocked out but that's the
worst guide in green is the second best
CRISPR guide in red is the best CRISPR
guide and you can see how the infective
'ti actually correlates with our CRISPR
editing very nicely now we also know
that this protein physically interacts
with the gag protein of HIV which is
required for budding and in fact when we
take a look at the viral particles that
come out of these knockout cells we see
that they're almost all immature and
oftentimes they'll bud together in these
long strings indicating that there is
strong HIV budding and maturation
defects so small molecules that would
inhibit the NHP to l1 gag interaction
could be effective small molecule
inhibitors down the line
so what did we learn from this study we
found that primary t-cell do indeed have
a very unique molecular architecture and
it's not always recapitulated by cell
line models so of the eighty-six host
factors that we found doing this work
again over 40 of them had not been
reported in any model cell line and so
these are new host factors that we
really need to understand their biology
better in order to fully grasp how HIV
replicates in vivo the second thing that
we learned is that CRISPR caste editing
using ribonucleoproteins is highly
efficient in primary t-cells again we're
doing all of this without any selection
without any integration of DNA it's just
a single pulse of these cells with
protein and RNA and we're able to
achieve using just three different guide
RNAs well over 70% editing
the third thing that we learned is that
the repair outcomes of crisper cast 9
editing can be predicted based on both
the sequence of the guide alone and
based on the chromatin architecture
which is something completely brand-new
that we weren't expecting to see from
this data and the fourth thing that we
learned is that protein-protein
interaction really represent an enriched
faction of host factors and so cut by
combining large data sets such as
proteomics and genetics like here we can
learn a lot about a new system very
rapidly
I just want to kind of close with the
point you know we all know how
scientific work is supposed to run you
we have literature and data and we're
supposed to take this and generate
hypotheses validated experimental
experimentally generate more hypotheses
and this cycle is supposed to improve
patient health and better treatment
strategies but in the age of big data
and patient cohorts and primary samples
we're getting so much data that our
ability to hi pop to generate hypotheses
is much much larger than our ability to
test them limitations in our models
limitations in our tools and most
importantly in a lot of cases
limitations in our own time prevent the
number of hypotheses we can reasonably
test and so improvements in our ability
to test hypotheses directly in primary
cell models in a high-throughput is
really critical for speeding this cycle
and improving patient health and so with
that I did want to just quickly
acknowledge a couple people before we
get to questions I want to acknowledge
Nevin Cronin who I did my postdoctoral
work with and who was instrumental in
getting this work done as well as our
fantastic collaborations with Alex
Marcin at UCSF jennifer doudna at UC
Berkeley and emai at the Chan Zuckerberg
bio hub West Sundquist at the University
of Utah and John Groce at UCSF and I
would also like to point out that the
protocol for how I do my primary t-cell
editing work is available on bio
archives number two oh five five zero
zero and with that I'm happy to take
take any questions
that was great thank you so much Judd
and I think that that protocol delisted
there is going to actually preempt a lot
of the questions that have come in I
might still toss a couple of those over
to you live but I'll give you a minute
to relax and I'll let our attendees put
in any last minute questions I did just
want to take a quick moment since we
have an audience who is is likely
thinking a lot about doing some sorts of
gene modulation in primary t-cells or
make sure you're aware that there is an
RNA AI technology that is very
successful for gene knockdown as opposed
to the knock out in primary t-cells and
many other cell types that are equally
very difficult to transfer um this might
be something that could it could really
complement or be a predecessor to the
CRISPR knockout work that that you just
presented so a few years ago we had
another guest speaker like yourself dr.
Michael Frehley who's with Trinity
University in Dublin and he spoke on his
publication of an RNA I screen for
regulators of PCL mobility and in that
study he used a self delivering s RNA
called
XLS irony so I'm not going to get into
any of his details but they just want to
make sure that there's awareness that
Excel s RNA is available it uses
patented chemical modifications that
enable uptake by nearly any cell type
I've listed a number of immunological
cell types here that might be of
interest it does not rely on any kind of
transparent viral vector or
electroporation it's a passive cell
uptake technology and so you'll be able
to find on our website a list of
publications that cite successful
delivery and target gene silencing in a
wide range of immunological and other
primary or difficult to transfer cell
types if you'd like to be the recording
of that webinar that discusses that use
of s RNA you can find it on our website
just click on the resources menu item
and then there'll be a drop down that
lets you click on webinar
and you'll be able to find it in that
list of webinars along with a number of
different crisper cast 9 educational
pieces we've done in the past those are
all available some tips and some
findings on HDR for precise gene editing
and knock in a raid crisper screening
and and crisper applications with
transcriptional activation
and finally just to circle back around
to today's topic the protocol that Jed
reviewed today can be carried out with
the editor synthetic crispr RNA product
line you can get either pre-designed or
your own designs delivered in tubes or
in a multi well plate for that ease of
use and support for the higher
throughput methods that you just heard
about you can get up to five
pre-designed CRISPR RNAs for each target
gene to ensure that redundancy that that
judd pointed out is being really
important to interpretation and
accounting for potential genetic
variation in your samples the second
component is the tracer RNA that is
combined with the crisp RNA to form the
full guide it is available in small or
and we have some new bulk sizes that
really help scale up with your needs
it's very easy to use there's no heating
cooling required for doing the
hybridization they're just combined an
equal molar amount the cast nine protein
of course is needed for RMP delivery we
do offer a very concentrated version
that's really useful for the protocol
recommendations for either
electroporation or nucleus xyn and
finally Judd mentions the use of a
control that can induce cell death and
he talked about some specific genes that
are known to be essential in P cells but
rather than having to dive into the
biology of your cell if you might be
unfamiliar with essential genes in your
system and needing to do that to find an
appropriate essential gene to knock out
we've developed to lethal positive
controls that are universal in their
ability to induce cell death they do
this by targeting repeat regions within
the genome and so with lots and lots of
breaks in the chromosomes we see
programmed cell death in a
dose-dependent manner that is cast nine
dependent but is independent of
essential gene expression
so with that I will go ahead and get
back to the questions at this time for
our audience two polling questions will
appear on your screen we do appreciate
you taking just a minute to click on the
best response for you to answer these
questions and remind you that you can
still submit questions for for Jed
into that Q&A section okay so Judd our
first question goes back to the the
repair prediction algorithm you
mentioned the sprout I think you called
it with me links for you is that going
to be something that is made available
or is it something that the the input is
just simply not something that can just
really easily be you know done over the
web yeah well what we're hoping to do is
design easy to use web applications that
can help people decide you know I've
designed this guide RNA for my
application I want to see what the
predicted repair outcome is and what
we're hoping to do is generate it from
our research a really easy to use web
tool that people can do that and that's
still under process the the algorithm
itself is still under review so we want
to make sure that we have it perfectly
optimized before we put it out there but
yeah hopefully that will be available
shortly okay and then on the same topic
there's a question so you're you're able
to map the repair outcomes which is
really fascinating but did you see
correlation in the efficiency of
knockout you know for instance were
those were those deletions pending to be
more efficient or insertions or was
there really not a correlation that you
could see
well overall we found way more deletions
and insertions but we found that even
our machine learning was unable to
predict the overall efficiency of the
guide we were hoping that we could use
this algorithm to determine you know
here's a sequence isn't more or less
efficient and we weren't able to do that
at least to our statistical satisfaction
the best that we were able to do is
identify these patterns that correlate
with insertions or deletions or again
these really long insertions okay so
even though you're able to sort of map
or potentially now predict repair
outcomes it's not necessarily going to
correlate to the kind of overall
efficiencies that you were seeing
exactly but again I was very heartened
by the fact that using the current you
know algorithms that are available to
design these guide RNAs you know we only
designed three per gene and on average
at least one of the three hit at least
75% as I was very encouraged by that
piece of data right right okay another
question kind of along those lines that
you just touched on maybe this is also
in the in the protocol what was the
source of your CRISPR design you know
how were they chosen were you using pre
designed to redesigning them yourselves
yeah so we actually used it from two
different sources we designed some of
them ourselves using a rule set - which
is available in a web interface using
the MIT CRISPR web tool but we also use
the number of guides from Dharma Khan's
pre-designed library and overall we
found that either way the pre design
library or designing them yourself
we see very similar patterns in the
overall efficiencies that we get
okay and then looks like we have to go
go get a couple more in here did you do
any expression analysis though were some
of the gene targets where were you
didn't see in effect were those simply
just not being expressed in those
t-cells or did you word with your gene
set such that they really should have
been expressed yeah so that's of the
gene set the genes had all originated
from proteomic data so the proteomic
data suggests that all of those gene
products should have been expressed now
that being said we didn't go and check
to validating all of our donors that our
targets were indeed expressed at that
time and so we don't know but we have a
high degree of confidence that they were
too deep there okay and then you'd
mentioned that there was a difference
between donors potentially due to a snip
and you show some good mapping there did
you essentially resolve that just by
having the multiple different CRISPR
designs that you were able to you know
maybe maybe discard the one that was
showing a big difference and look at the
others or how did you resolve that yeah
isn't that cool as you know working with
all these different donor cells it just
you know it really blew my mind how
different you know each donor to donor
was and these these snips created large
disagreements in editing efficiency but
luckily you know that's why we designed
three guides per gene not only because
it's hard to predict which one is going
to be most efficient but also to just in
case we accidentally hit one of these
snips and then I showed you one example
of that but there were actually quite a
few of them but a long thing that gets
it's something that gets discussed but
to actually see the evidence of it you
know makes it makes it very real I know
I was just crazy we couldn't believe it
it was a lot of work getting all the
sequencing data but we were so happy
that we did because we we just learned
so much from it hey I'd highly recommend
that if people are using this technology
either in primary cells or in the cell
line you know
if you can get sequencing data from that
specific line or cell type that you're
using that is way more useful for
designing your guides and aligning it
just to the reference sequence or design
multiple guides like we did here it's
very important right makes sense so with
that let me just wrap up with one just
sort of what what you might want your
parting thoughts to be so obviously you
you have all of the kind of the nuts and
bolts of the workflow written up in that
protocol that will make sure is is made
available to all the attendees but what
would you say is kind of the biggest
consideration or pitfall to avoid in in
really taking on you know this CRISPR
caste 9 editing in primary cells
I think the most important thing to keep
in mind if you're going to be doing gene
editing in primary cells is that you
monitor the efficiency of your knock out
every time that you do it so we found
that donor to donor you don't always get
good correlation genes gene you don't
always get correlation and so being sure
that you validate the reagents that
you're using and the knock out after
you've generated it every time you do it
is really essential to be sure that
you're tracking your phenotype correctly
that was one of our big takeaways from
this work all right excellent well I
will let you end on that then thank you
to the audience for all those great
questions and Judd thank you very much
for the presentation and in all of your
insights in answering those questions
absolutely thank you so much for having
me you bet
I also want to in dition to thanking you
again thanking lab roots and horizon
discovery for underwriting today's
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through March of next year and
lab roots will send all registered
attendees and email when it's available
to replay on-demand and so we certainly
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event and then following
that it will be hosted as well on the
thermicon segment of the horizon
discovery website so with that until
next time thanks everyone for joining
and have a great day